quiero comenzar esta plática con una con
un comentario que seguramente ustedes
van a compartir
es este puedan ver bien
también es un día más en el que
probablemente no ha utilizado tu
conocimiento sobre las placas tectónicas
o qué tal vez no se ha utilizado el
conocimiento que tenga sobre lo que es
la mitosis no me quiero detener en lo
mucho que el aprendizaje puede aportar a
nuestras vidas porque es innegable que
puedo hacer un montón sino en el hecho
de que en nuestra vida diaria poco a
poco a veces puede ser de poca utilidad
por eso a veces se nos olvida quiénes
son mis estudiantes o quiénes son
estudiantes ustedes saben que no sé que
también recuerdan todo lo que vieron el
semestre pasado y si hace 10 20 30 años
que salieron de la escuela todo eso está
a años luz de tus necesidades del día de
hoy
profe para que me va a servir esto es
una pregunta que todo el mundo demos
hicimos en algún momento y también es
una pregunta que como docentes
escuchamos todo el tiempo la respuesta
más rápida la con la que siempre quiero
aportar algo y es es para salir rápido
del apuro es siempre les digo te sirve
para pasar al siguiente nivel para pasar
el siguiente año para que tengan tu
título y puedas continuar
pero si consideramos el hecho de que en
promedio un adolescente pasa 9.600 horas
en la escuela desde que entre el primer
grado de secundaria y que sale de
bachillerato y como si los que son
universitarios saben que no solamente es
el tiempo que estás en el aula sino
también todo lo que inviertas a tus
proyectos y a tus investigaciones creo
que es importante y creo que es muy
legítimo que te preguntes para qué sirve
todo eso es todo tiempo perdido al final
de cuentas si de verdad quieres saber
algo lo único que tienes que hacer es
sacar tu celular y buscarlo en google
hace de hecho esta semana pasada uno de
mis alumnos me comentaba mis esto
refiriéndose a la escuela no tiene nada
que ver con el futuro
para que me va a servir es la escuela
tan relevante como lo pensamos en algún
momento la escuela tiene un inicio en la
parte como en la parte en la era de
industrialización donde mucha de la de
la mentalidad era de manufactura querían
que las cosas las personas también
incluidas en el proceso tuvieran como
una uniformidad en el resultado
querían que al final todo tuviera como
algo que hiciera los checklist y que
fuera como que cumpliera ciertas
certificaciones en el momento que se
instala la escuela cumple su cumple su
cometido y lo hace pues de una forma
pues bien y mal le sirve a ellos a
través de los años ha ido cambiando
podría parecer que la escuela no ha
cambiado demasiado porque los cambios o
sea los tiempos también cambiaban de
forma bastante lenta
hoy en día cambian vertiginosamente
entre mi primera generación y esta
última hay cambios radicales en cuanto a
los jóvenes y eso que solamente han
pasado ocho años
la escuela si está cambiando hay
muchísimos procesos y hay muchísimas
opciones que podemos encontrar de hecho
si tú entras a la plata a la plataforma
de te vas encontrar que un montón de
pensadores de docentes de grandes
educadores que están revolucionando la
forma en la que se entiende la educación
pero mientras todo esto sucede y podemos
convertirnos en todo lo que deberíamos
ser también es tu tiempo el que está
pasando si eres estudiante es tu tiempo
el que está pasando en este momento y
para cuando encontremos las respuestas a
esta interrogante para qué sirve
probablemente ya te habrás graduado así
que no te puedes cruzar de brazos y
esperar una respuesta de forma pasiva
en el 2016 tuvimos la mayor cantidad de
graduados que existió en la historia de
la humanidad
es decir nunca ha habido esta cantidad
de personas que estén educadas que
tengan una educación que está comprobado
mediante una licenciatura y que de hecho
sepa leer y escribir tan sólo con eso
nunca habíamos tenido tanta gente tan
preparada por eso creo que es más
importante ahora que nunca el que no
solo te preocupe el éxito académico por
sí mismo sino que quieras tener las
habilidades para para construir te una
buena vida
entonces con esto en mente pensado en
tres cosas para las que te puede servir
la escuela también les traje en bonos
porque mis alumnos les fascinan los
bonos entonces espero que también usted
les guste la primera de ellas es la
escuela te va a servir para aprender a
administrar tu tiempo y energía tengo
alumnos de más los alumnos más jóvenes
que tengo están en primera secundaria
tienen entre 12 y 13 años y luego ellos
me dicen mis estoy súper agobiada y ya
no puedo con la vida tienen 13 años de
crisis puede gobbi alguien de 13 años y
sin embargo de verdad lo hacen y están
estresados y muchas veces y esto digo
londres nada da risa pero cuando ya
empiezan a tener ataques de pánico o
empiezan a tener ataques de ansiedad y
se sueltan a llorar porque se les olvidó
hacer x oye o porque no sabían que
tenían quize me estoy dando cuenta de
que hay de fondo o se han aunado al
hecho de que si tienen muchas
actividades tienen en las tardes
academias tienen deportes tienen tutores
tienen tienen vida social muy activa
también tiene las cosas clásicas de que
se distraen viendo series o de que están
en sus redes sociales un montón
aparte de eso de fondo hay un hay una
mala administración de su tiempo y de su
energía
el problema es que creo que lo han
aprendido de todos nosotros los que
somos adultos creemos que si estamos
agobiados y estresados estamos haciendo
más y nuestro o lo que sea que tengamos
que hacer es muchísimo más importante
porque dijo lo estamos haciendo
así agobia decimos y no nos podía dormir
y nos desvelamos haciéndolo
pero creo que es importante que como
estudiantes sepan que pueden romper el
patrón que hay otra forma de hacer las
cosas y que aparte está en el momento
ideal para poder hacerlo o sea ahorita
este es el momento en el que puedes
checar si a ti te sirve utilizar el
calendario o si te sirve utilizar tu
celular si lo logra sumar puedes
utilizarlo también puedes usar tu agenda
puedes usar una pulsión o puedes hacer
muchas cosas con eso
lo importante es que tienes una cosa
tienes ahorita un margen de error
grandísimo si te equivocas y se te
olvida llevar la cartulina a la escuela
realmente no pasa nada pero conforme vas
creciendo el margen de error es cada vez
menor entonces aprovecha esa oportunidad
que tienes que ser un momento único en
el que puedes poner en práctica
o sea echar a perder a lo mejor regalo
de todos nos tienen constantes
oportunidades entonces todas las tareas
todos los proyectos en lugar de verlos
como uno otro más
puedes verlo esto es una oportunidad
para aprender a administrar me
el segundo punto
vamos a considerar esta frase es el
hombre no se descubre se construye me
encanta esa frase porque es súper
experiencia esperanzadora significa que
todo lo que cuando te imaginas tu a
futuro incluso siendo adultos cuando ves
una visión ideal de quien quiere ser
puedes ver un ente de cualidades un
montón de cosas que te encantaría tener
y lo padre es que no se no se te acaba
el tiempo o no es como que a tus 18 años
va a venir un hada madrina que no sabías
que existía y vas y tú eres súper líder
paz increíble comunicador o sea todo
este tipo de cosas de hecho están en tu
control puedes construirlas y estás en
la escuela que tiene una cosa
maravillosa que es que se sobreentiende
que no sabes hacer lo que estás
aprendiendo nadie espera que de verdad
sepas pararte en público nadie sepa que
seas maravilloso a la hora de actuar o
que tengas un talentazo en matemáticas
porque incluso si tienes el talento pero
no lo construyes por realmente se va a
quedar en algo que pudo pudo ser y no
fue entonces digo en el colegio donde yo
estoy el semestre pasado uno de los
profesores se le ocurrió lanzar el reto
era una tarea super sencilla de que era
resolver el cubo rubik seguramente
alguna vez lo han visto cuando yo estaba
pequeña hacerlo era sumamente imposible
porque era algo así como de genios ahora
está un montón de tutoriales pero de
todos modos implica implica que tienes
que aprender varios algoritmos
mis alumnos lo hicieron estaban
emocionadísimos y cada vez empezaron a
hacerlo más rápido y más complejo
también he tenido alumnos que siendo
teniendo quince y seis años han podido
armar eventos así gigantescos para 100
200 niños de escasos recursos siendo un
grupo pequeño de 15 y 6 y solo bajo
liderazgo de un solo maestro estás en la
escuela y tienes toda esta oportunidad
de todas estas ocasiones para poder
convertirse en la persona que quiere ser
hay concursos hay retos hay proyectos si
tu sueño siempre ha sido tener una
hermosa caligrafía y un montón de
cartulinas que puedes hacer un montón de
trabajos en los que puedes practicarlo
cuando uno crece y todos ya que sabe uno
sale uno al mundo adulto
aprender a adquirir una habilidad o
mejorar una habilidad implica muchísimo
más tiempo y organización porque tienes
que salirte de tu rutina y tienes que
emplear diferentes recursos para hacer
el esfuerzo de hecho adquirirlo pero
cuando eres cuando estás en la escuela
de todos modos ya estás ahí a fuerza
tienes que estar 8 horas así que mejor
aprovecharlas
este punto es acerca de la frustración
todo el mundo nos hemos frustrado lo
importante es qué haces cuando estás
frustrado yo he tenido alumnos
frustrados porque alguien ha sacado una
mejor nota o porque ellos no sacaron lo
que creían o porque perdieron nunca hood
también he tenido alumnos que cuando
estamos explicando un tema que es un
poquito más complejo se cierran en un no
entiendo y lloran y se estresan y de ahí
no lo sacas yo siempre pensado y también
se los digo es mira si no te aprendes el
pasivo de la voz pasiva del inglés o
todos los verbos irregulares la verdad
es que no tiempos de verdad de verdad no
te mueres no pasa nada pero si hacía
enfrentas las cosas que no te gustan o
las cosas que no entiendes vas a sufrir
un montón porque las cosas la vida hay
un montón de cosas que ni entendemos y
nos gustan
así que analizamos cómo estamos llevando
la frustración una de mis alumnas me
compartió su secreto nos estaba diciendo
que ella cada vez que se siente que las
cosas están saliendo de control se
siente súper enojada lo que hace es
golpear pan porque pan le preguntamos o
porque el pan no se rompe y así como
ella tiene su herramienta terapéutica tú
también puedes descubrir qué es lo que a
ti te ayuda para sobrellevar las
dificultades fortalece te ahora que
estás en un ambiente donde está tu
familia estás en casa
y realmente tienes todo un
acompañamiento y apoyo detrás
y bonus es acerca de las habilidades de
comunicación en todas sus clases y en
todas las clases vas a utilizar
esa fuerza a comunicarte de alguna u
otra forma
y no solamente me quiero referir a la
parte de gramática y ortografía que es
súper necesaria y hay amplio ejemplos de
eso sino a dos otras cosas la primera es
la claridad de ideas que te la piden no
solamente a la hora de redactar sino que
también te puedes o se puede dar en tu
vida muchísimo éxito interpersonal te
puede salvar de muchísimos dramas muchas
veces nos podemos quejar que los demás
no nos entienden de que tú misma no me
entienda y papá no me entiende mis
amigos no me comprenden bien muchos se
usan mucho tiene que ver con el hecho de
que probablemente ni tú mismo sepas
enumerarlas en
no puedas poner las ideas en orden ni
siquiera en tu cabeza y es mucho más
difícil comunicarla siquiera tú las
tienes claras entonces práctica tus
actividades tus habilidades de
comunicación
y otra parte de la comunicación es la
estructura pero ya dije la estructura
ahora la otra siguiente parte es la
forma la forma en la que nos comunicamos
práctica la habilidad de ser amable o
ser amable con los que te caen bien con
los compañeros que no hablas con
aquellos que te caen mal incluso con las
personas que están en el área de
servicio en la parte de limpieza con los
guardias o con tus profesores incluso en
esas ocasiones donde a lo mejor no sacas
la nota que tú esperabas todas estas
cosas no son exclusivas de las personas
o sea de los jóvenes que todavía van a
la escuela creo que todos podemos ver la
vida y ver las cosas y las
circunstancias y preguntarnos de qué me
va a servir esto pero desde una posición
o desde una actitud en la que te sabes
dueño de las situaciones que sabes que
las cosas están a tu servicio y que tú
puedes decidir cómo vas a utilizarlas lo
que yo siempre ha deseado para mis
alumnos y en general para todos los
alumnos y para todos los estudiantes es
que cuando salgan de la escuela sea el
bachillerato de la universidad o de la
maestría es que no solamente salgan con
un título sino que salgan con las
habilidades para forjarse un buen fue
una buena vida
que el mismo espíritu o sea lo mismo que
les llevó a preguntarse para qué me va a
servir esto se convierte en esta fuerza
proactiva que espero que les lleve no a
esperar una respuesta sino a salir a
buscarla muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]